في مقابل الكشف الامريكي هناك كشف روسي
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي اعلن انه
اكتشف برنامجا امريكيا فائق التطور
استخدمته واشنطن لاختراق الاف اجهزه
الايفون في روسيا واشنطن وجدت الطريقه
الامثل لمراقبه علاقات كل الدول مع روسيا
وهي التجسس على الدبلوماسيين الاجانب في
روسيا العمليه شملت هواتف دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق والصين الا ان التجسس لم
يستثني ممثلي دول الناتو ايضا ممن
يستخدمون هواتف ايفون لكن الامر الاكثر
خطوره بالنسبه لروسيا هم الاف المسؤولين
الذين يستخدمون الهواتف الامريكيه وهذه
هنا سوره
خلال قمه العشرين في بالي وزير الخارجيه
الروسي يرتدي ساعه ابل
ويستخدم جهاز ايفون وهو ليس استثناء فخمسه
وعشرون مليون
يستخدمون منتجات ابل الامن الفيدرالي كشف
تفاصيل الاختراق وكان مساعده في ذلك شركه
كاسبرسكي الروسيه للحمايه السيبرانيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات